President Biden having an excellent time
at the White House Easter egg roll and
hopping right into speculation over 2024
looks like everyone was there the giant
human-sized bunnies mixing it up with
influence peddling members of his family
like Hunter it was all fun and games
until Biden dangled this carrot in front
of millions of anxious Democrats
for 2024. I plan on at least three or
four more Easter egg rolls at least
three or four maybe five maybe five
maybe six what the hell are you saying
that uh
uh taking part in our upcoming election
you know being the good you know the guy
who's pushed him out come on help
plan on running now but we're not
prepared to announce it yet all right
whatever although the president isn't
prepared to make things officially does
have a re-election strategy ready to go
an army of tick-tock influencers yet the
same chinese-owned app that lawmakers
are considering Banning because of
National Security concerns the plan
seems obvious gen Z has fallen out of
love with Joe and he has to juice those
numbers somehow but it gets more
annoying the bite Administration is even
considering creating a separate briefing
room at the White House for the tick
talkers so brace yourself for more of
this
hi my name is Cooper and this is a day
in my life as a White House intern hey
Jenny I booked you a nail appointment
love yeah I didn't tell you to do that
it's called initiative hi White House
this is Cooper I don't think so
oh it doesn't matter
and Jen don't forget to have fun so
Jesse this is interesting their strategy
is enlisting the dumbest most vacuous
most destructive least experienced
idiots on Earth otherwise known as
influencers from Tick Tock what does
that tell you about the Democratic party
they don't care that they're enlisting
something that destroys people's minds
it tells me you buy influencers when you
can't influence anybody yourself Joe
Biden's idea of persuading someone is to
say come on man the guy doesn't Inspire
he doesn't influence you know Barack
Obama sent a thrill Down Chris Matthews
leg he didn't pay an influencer to send
the thrill he sent that thrill himself
Joe Biden can't send Thrills because the
man has no original ideas ever he
plagiarized his way through life he's
never said anything that's anyone that
ever got up off of their seat and went
like that so this is their new strategy
is to pay influencers and then he's
going to have surrogates campaign for
him he stays in Delaware and then JB
pritzker goes out and gives a speech now
if the media
was having a really hard time trying to
say you know Trump's in bed with Russia
how is this guy not in bed with China
he's inviting an army of young people
with phones with a Chinese spy app into
the White House for two years and giving
them offices
I mean how easy is it these guys are
just Hired Guns anyway Greg you wave a
bunch of cash in someone's face and say
you can have the key to the White House
they're going to do whatever you want
and the fact that the guy broke his
re-election announcement to a weatherman
during an Easter egg roll tells you
something what happened the last time Al
Roker was at the White House I think he
sharted yes he did this was a much
better story for Al I don't even think
Biden was planning on making this
announcement he just got guilted into it
oh can you break some news for me Joe
sure out why not Jesse I love how you
bring a bit of History to these topics a
lot of people wouldn't have remembered
their shardable moment that's a
disgusting juxtaposition and no but
bringing it back it kind of sets the
stage for my next question
so doesn't this explain why the uh the
restrict bill just died because they it
deliberately made it so broad that it
couldn't pass it was supposed to be
about Tick Tock and then they made it
about all these other private websites
and that was because they didn't want it
because this is what what they really
want right because then so now they're
betwixt and between which is a little
phrase I heard because they know that
they they want to try to make sure that
they have the youth vote and more on
that in just a moment and also at the
time when they announced it at the
briefing room they couldn't answer if he
why he would be calling for the restrict
act at the same time he did a tick tock
video for St Patrick's Day and they were
like oh yeah we can't really we don't
really know and maybe and maybe they
weren't told do you remember at the
beginning of the administration when
they first got there they weren't even
allowed to have a Peloton because of the
concern about the Wi-Fi and the things
so now to Jesse's Point bringing all of
these people in with the tick tock on
their phones you're not allowed to have
tick tock on your government phone
but you can have Tick Tock as an
influencer on your phone when you go
into the White House and also how are
you going to allow Tick-Tock influencers
for your campaign to have office space
at the White House yeah if you're going
to open up an office space because you
think social media influencers are
important to the discussion well then
that means you have to be open to
everybody coming in and do you really
want that I don't think so however a
couple of things the Millennials were
for Banning Tick Tock in the most recent
poll 45 to 25 the youngsters 18 to 29
year olds were not but they were only 49
for it so there is an opening here where
you could have gotten everyone together
and say let's band together let's all
use a different platform to communicate
but these college town turnouts Greg
last week when you were away and we
missed you very much yeah there was a
election in Wisconsin the Democrats
mopped the floor with the Republicans
and one of the ways they did that is
they ran up the vote totals in the two
big college towns and that's what they
did in Arizona and they're planning it
all across the country so there is a
method to their Madness but it is Matt
so Katie you know they say influencers
but they never say whether it's good or
bad influence I mean generally the ones
that I see strike me as mentally unwell
uh people that seek attention and are
driven by Envy and I don't think they
have a keen grasp on inflation Laura I
mean the guy with the long nails doesn't
understand inflation yeah exactly the
nail salon is a lot more expensive now
yeah maybe maybe he does you never know
no data is right I mean people always
say you don't need to reach out to the
youth vote because they don't turn out
to vote so it's a waste of time that's
not a waste of time as we've seen for
Democrats lately but when it comes to
The Tick Tock issue Republicans and some
Democrats few of them some of them talk
about Tick Tock as a national security
problem to protect the country from a
foreign adversary who is poisoning the
minds of the youth who are making these
monsters out of young people but
Democrats most of them in the White
House talk about it in terms of vote
turnout in terms of political problems
they are concerned that if they protect
National Security they will somehow
damage themselves politically and that's
a problem for them and they do have this
huge issue where there are filming
videos inside the White House where
there are classified spaces like Skiffs
on Tick Tock where the Chinese
government has the location all the
information on the phone from the White
House but then I want to comment real
quickly on Joe Biden saying he's going
to be rolling Easter eggs for however
many years the White House can't say
that he's not running for election
because then he becomes even more
irrelevant right he becomes even more of
a lame duck than he would be if he were
to say I I am running so they can't say
that until they decide he's either in
and who's going to be the backup and
Gavin newsom's the guy that really wants
that position so Geraldo let's say you
were gen Z now would you probably would
have been an influencer
what would you be doing on Tick Tock
when I wouldn't be to Dana's point on
the election the various elections the
most consequential election of 2023 was
in Wisconsin the Wisconsin Supreme Court
uh Madison Wisconsin where my wife
attended University of Wisconsin uh
there are precincts where one particular
Precinct where there were 40 votes cast
in 2019 there were 400 votes cast 500
sorry 500 votes cast 500 versus 44 votes
gen Z is the key to Joe Biden's
reelection he's definitely running he
can't win without these kids the kids
are the wokest generation ever they are
motivated they are turned on my daughter
for example uh two weeks ago less than
two weeks ago on a national school
walkout day to protest gun violence uh
very appropriate today it's a private
school what happened yet so you paid for
her and she walked out but I she walked
out she came back and I appreciated the
fact that she was motive invaded that
she wanted the end to gun violence these
kids are the key to the the coming
election the Democrats understand it the
Republicans better get on board
otherwise they're going to get their
butts kick all right hi everyone I'm
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now